(slurp)
(upbeat guitar music)
- It looks really weird.
- It's never come into my life,
I've seen it at restaurants.
- Whenever friends do try
it, I'm always hesitant.
- I rarely went to a place that served it,
and then when I was there, I was like
"that looks too weird,
I'm gonna have the chicken
I can't pronounce instead."
- This is like, classic boba.
- It's sealed.
- I hope that it tastes
like chocolate milk.
(popping)
(gags)
- It just felt like
tadpoles flew in my mouth.
- I don't know how I feel about
chewing these weird gummy things.
- It's like chewing on a trampoline.
- I'm like, pleasantly surprised.
- The tea is delicious.
- It's very similar to this Indian ja.
- I like it but I don't get it.
- It's like expecting to get
a Game Boy for Christmas,
and then your parents get
you a Game Boy Advance.
- I would totally go for this again.
- This looks like a witch's brew.
- I have no idea what taro is.
- Ooh, that's good.
- I really like it, I like
it more than the first one.
- It's a floral, kind of
sweet potato kind of flavor.
- Sweet but not too sweet.
- Chewing on something matches
the flavor of what's going on here.
- I would prefer the tea without the boba.
- [voiceover] Honeydew milk tea?
- This does not look natural at all.
- This is really good.
- Mm-mm.
- (shrieks) Nooo!
- Whoa, that tastes exactly like honeydew.
- So sweet and so sour at the same time.
- It's not overly powerful,
it's not too sweet.
- This makes the most
sense to chew the balls,
cause you're used to chewing
when you eat honeydew.
- I feel like honeydew
is done better in boba
than it is like, on its own.
- I'm liking it more and more.
- Maybe I need to go out and
start drinking more boba tea.
- It almost makes drinking tea stressful.
- I'm a convert.
- I like the squishy.
- I would drink this
now. I'm glad I tried it.
[voiceover] These balls confuse me a ton.
I don't know whether to swallow them,
or just like, let them
hang out in my mouth.
(laughs)
It's impossible not to
make jokes about balls
when you're drinking this tea.